hi my name is Phil welcome to my youtube
channel maze the troll tips and tricks
in this video I'm going to show you how
to machine this part I got right here
this is going to be our third demo piece
and it has turning drilling and milling
in it so let's get started programming
this park
all right here's our third part what it
looks like so the first thing we're
going to do is go to the program screen
the left button go to program program
file and we're going to select a work
number that is not listed up here so 23
is not up here so we're going to choose
that work number so go back to program
pushed work number I think to 3 input
and it says program number ones not
found if it's a new program push this
button so push program now it's asking
us mais otro Lori I a and we're going
with Mesa troll on this work piece
material we're going to choose aluminum
maximum outside diameter of workpiece is
three point two five inches minimum
diameter of workpiece is zero it does
not have a hole in it workpiece length
is three inches long max spindle RPM
limit is the g fifty for the entire
program and i don't want to run the
chuck past 2,000 RPM so type in 2000
finish allowance on x this is the stock
that the ruffer's are going to leave for
the finishers to clean up I'm going to
leave ten thousands on the diameter so
type in point zero one finish allowance
on Z is five thousand and the stock
removal of the work face this is how
much we're facing off the end of the
part in this case a hundred thousand
input now the first process we're going
to do is turn on the cooling for that we
need to push these three arrows go over
here to my
and then down arrow so now the next
thing we're going to do is face off the
excess stock on our part so we're going
to push edge and then again the surface
speed for rough cut finish cut and depth
of cut we can set automatically by
pushing this button the roughing tool
number we're going to use tool for which
is our CNM G upset one finish tool is
tool for offset one starting point on X
is going to be our stock size of three
point two five input starting point on Z
is going to be the hundred thousand
point one final point on X and final
point on Z are both zero surface
roughness we're going to choose number
seven what I didn't explain before is
the lower numbers are a much coarser
feed rate and the higher numbers are a
finer feed rate five six and seven
they're in the middle but seven is close
to a thirty to finish a little finer
than a thirty-two so I usually choose
that so down arrow so we faced the edge
of the part off
so now what we need to do is describe
this OD line right here that starts at
two inches and it has a hundred
thousands chamfer at the front of it so
we're machining bar stock we're on the
open geometry on the outside cutting
point on X is three point two five
cutting point on Z and zero surface
speed for rough cut again the auto comes
up push that if you wish to override it
you can do that roughing tool number
we're going to stay with tool for offset
one finish it with tool for offset one
so now what we need to do is describe
the shape this is going to be a linear
starting corner it's going to be the
hundred thousandths point one final
point on X is going to be two inches and
the final point on Z is going to be
seven hundred thousandths with a hundred
thousand corner at the end of the line
so we push this radius button here first
that changes whatever value I type in
into a radius and you can see the yellow
our pop-up surface roughness is seven
down arrow now let's take a look at our
shape so right button fig your check and
we've got a hundred thousands coming off
the face and then we've got the diameter
turned up to the stock size if we push
the store button we can see what changes
we have from now until we're done
programming it's a push store go back to
program and now we need to make this
horizontal line vertical lines as you
saw in this trait are done automatically
so we need to focus on the horizontal
line and it has a 2.5 inch diameter with
a hundred thousandths radius at the
front of them don't push linear push
radius point one input final point in X
is two point five input and the final
point on Z it's going to be 1.75 inches
with a two hundred thousand radius at
the end of the line
so radius point to input surface
roughness is seven down arrow right
button fig your check
so this kept the image from before and
we can see we added another linear line
to the program we're not done with it
yet so let's go back to program we need
to make one more linear line and that's
in order to chamfer this part right here
so go linear starting corner is a
hundred thousandth final plate on X it's
going to be our stock diameter of three
point two five final point on Z is going
to be one point seven five plus the
hundred thousandth chamfer plus mm to
roll the insert over the top of the
radius if we don't do that it leaves a
little tiny burr there so one point
eight five two is our finished length
surface roughness is seven down arrow
shape in right button finger check
now we can see the two champers on it
but let's blow this up a little bit to
get more detail so push the scale button
move the cursors up and over and that
white box will be the center of the
screen when we change the scale so let's
give it a larger scale of like 1 enter
and that blew it up a little bit so
let's go back to program so now what we
need to do is we need to punch this hole
in the center of the park so this is the
first menu that comes up but there's not
a drill on the first menu so we push the
three arrows here's the drill
push that and the drilling type has four
different selections zero drilling
speeds in and feeds out at the same feed
rate and it's useless on this machine
number one pecking feeds in and then
Rapids out to the start Rapids back in
feeds a little more Rapids back out as a
chip clear number two pecking feeds in
Rapids out a little bit and breaks the
chip and number three reamer feeds in
and then feeds out that doubled the feed
rig most the time we're going to select
number one pecking
drill diameter in this case it's point
six nine depth of first cut again we got
an auto that comes up so if we push that
it will auto-populate our depth of cut
our feeds and speeds so the first field
is the depth of first cut this is how
much it's going to take when it first
enters the workpiece the second one is
the D criminal depth of cut this is how
much it's going to - off of the depth of
cut on each subsequent pass and then
finally the minimum depth of cut
four deep holes when this goes down the
minimum depth of cut is going to be
three millimeters for 118,000 surface
speed and the feed rate the tool were
using is tool 13 offset one starting
point and Z is going to be the front of
the part the final point on Z is going
to be this whole depth of one point five
seven and that goes to the end of the
hole on this older machine that does not
compensate for the drill point angle the
newer machines will go down to the major
diameter of the drill pass the drill
point on this one it does not so type in
one point five seven input down arrow
and then right button figure check
and now we've got a hole punched in the
part again you can see there is no angle
shown on the hole go back to program so
now what we need to do is describe this
bore size the bore it's a nine hundred
thousand four with the one hundred
thousand chamfer at the front of it so
again we're using bar stock in this time
and it's still open geometry cutting
point on X it's going to be a drill
diameter point six nine cutting point on
Z is zero again surface speed for
roughing we push Auto and it auto
populates our feeds and speeds for us
roughing tool number is tool twelve
offset one finish tool is tool twelve
offset one so the next thing we're going
to do is the linear starting corner is a
hundred thousand final plate on X is
nine hundred the final point on Z is
going to be one point three inches
and the final corner I forgot to put on
the print is a fifty thousand radius at
the bottom of the hole so push radius
point zero five input surface roughness
is seven down arrow and now let's
chamfer the hole going into the drill
so go linear let's give it a twenty
thousand chamfer point six nine for the
hole size and then we got to go this
dimension one point three plus twenty
thousand-plus mm to roll that insert
over the chamfer so one point three two
two input seven down arrow shape in
and then end I haven't touched on the
end process in the machine yet but this
is very powerful when you need to do
multiple parts or switch between
programs and etc it's very useful for
bar pulley on this process we just need
to push end and leave everything zero so
let's go to the right button did you
check
and there's our board so now let's look
at the toolpath so left button go to
program that gets us out of edit mode
push check and then check continue so
what it's going to do is it's going to
rough the face and it's going to finish
the face and it's going to rough the OD
toolpath the race to erase what the
graphics there's the finish Oh deep ass
now it's going to drill the hole in the
center now it's going to rough the bore
the path of race and now it's finishing
the board so this is how it's programmed
but this is really not how I want to run
this part I would like to rough out the
part and then run the finish tools so
I'll show you how to do that now so go
to layout and if you notice it's got r1
which is the coolant r2 is the edge
process this is the roughing process and
then the finish process and so on down
the line
now if we push rough priority on this
screen and then push the input button
notice how it reorganizes all roughing
processes upfront and then finish
processes at the end and this is fine
for how its programmed but to eliminate
one tool change I want to move this
finish bar in process above the finished
turning process so to do that move your
arrows down and it's going to insert a
line above where the cursor is so go
move
process to insert it's going to be a
finished process number five input and
now if you look we're roughing it with
tool for drilling it with 13 roughing it
with tool 12 finishing the tool 12 and
then come back with the tool for to
finish the face and finish the LD you've
got to be careful on this screen because
you can actually put the finish tools
above the roughing tools and crash the
park so when you play with the layout
you got to be wary of that issue the
newer machines have a protection against
that on this one because you're doing it
manually it allows you to do that so
let's go back to the program check cool
path erase and then check continue
now it's rough in the outside
now it's changing tools to drill it
ruff the boar
we'll fat the race
finish the board
finish the face
and now finished the OD of the profile
and it's done so now from here what we
need to do is set the work ship so we're
going to come over and set the z0 for
this program
[Music]
all right we're ready to set the work
ship so come up here to manual come over
to the face of the part
and let's turn the spindle on like 300
rpm
there we go
all right we're touching the face we
easily cut off a hundred thousand so
stop the spindle come over here and go
to program go to program file arrow down
arrow over to the Z offset we're going
to teach it so push Z upset teach point
one we're a hundred thousands in front
of our zero because this is the rough
stock for machining off get input and
now we've taught Z so now let's go to
the position screen and we're in program
number one right now so that's why the Z
is not at 100,000 so push Pato push work
number twenty three input and now we're
at a hundred thousand suis on the Edit
on the run side we're on program 23 so
let's go to the Trey screen so left
button trace and now we can see our
turning tool just like it is on the part
so now what we need to do is go to auto
turn on the coolant in auto not in
manual and then let's sit cycle start
and run this part
[Applause]
making a stew roughing passage
all right now comes the drill
[Music]
and we're done drilling the park
bring up the boring bar
all right done roughing it now finished
past of the boring bar
now it's time to come up with tool for
so right now it's cutting a little bit
of air before it touched apart in later
videos I'll show you how to I'll show
you a trick to get rid of that for this
it's fine
and we are done two minutes and 56
seconds all right now in this case I
want to show you guys how to rerun a
process in order to dial in the the part
so let's say the OD was mm bigger than
it should have been first thing we're
going to do is going to go to the where
screen so we're going to push the left
button go tool set and then we're going
to arrow down to where offset number 1
in X and we're going to go - point 0 0 2
input so this is going to take mm off on
the diameter on 204 so now what we need
to do is go back and let's go to the
program to the layout screen and we want
to run the last process the f3 the
finish 3 process so what we're going to
do is going to push this button down
here single process go to position and
it's asking us which process do you want
to run we're going to push finish 3
input and then we're going to we can do
the same thing on the tray screen so
finish 3 input
there's the coolant now let's close the
door and let's hit cycle start
and one thing to note it says two point
four nine eight on that diameter on this
machine and on every mazak that I've
come across the where shows up in the
geometry when you're running the part
some people found that annoying but it's
a nature of the main set you can
actually see there's a we're going on
because it does adjust the geometry
alright and we are done and if we check
it check the size if we like it or we
can rerun it again but that's how to
rerun a finish pass using Mesa tool so
we're done with the part blow it off and
that's our our finished part
if you liked this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe also push the
note of the Bell notification to be
notified when we get new videos coming
out thanks and keep watching